Consider the
following experiment.
You have two pieces of
metal, copper and zinc,
which you connect
to conducting wires.
And you then submerge the
metals in an electrolyte,
in this case vinegar.
You will observe that bubbles
will form around the zinc
but not on the copper.
The metals seem
dissimilar in this way.
And if you then connect the
two wires holding the metals,
something changes.
Tiny bubbles begin to form
around the copper terminal.
It seems as though something
is being pulled from the zinc
through the wire,
allowing a reaction
to occur on the copper side.
And it turns out this is a
flow of electrical charge,
as electrons are pulled
away from the zinc
towards the copper through the
conductive path in the wire.
Think of this flow as the
result of a charge imbalance,
or electrical pressure
between the two metals.
As compared to the
instantaneous discharge
observed with static
electricity experiments.
And towards the end
of the 18th century,
Alessandro Volta had been
investigating this effect.
More importantly, he found
that chaining these cells
together would amplify
this flow of charge.
And by 1800, he simplified
things even further,
removing the jar, which
provided more electrolyte
than was actually needed.
He writes, "A few dozen
small round disks of copper,
pieces of coin for example, and
equal number of plates of zinc,
I prepare circular
pieces of spongy matter
capable of retaining water.
I continue coupling a plate
of copper with one zinc,
and always in the same
order, and interpose
between each of these
couples a moistened disk.
This continues until I
have a column as high
as possible without
danger of it falling."
This is known famously as the
voltaic pile, the first battery
in history to provide
a continuous flow
of electrical charge or current.
More cells resulted in an
increased electrical pressure
at the two ends, and
electrical pressure
was an early term for what we
now call voltage, after Volta.
Now if the two leads
of a voltaic pile
were brought into direct
contact, a series of shocks
could be observed.
Now at first, the utility
of electric current
as a communication method was
not immediately obvious, aside
from faint sparks and bubbles.
One idea was to use the presence
of bubbles to signal letters,
and the bubble telegraph
used this method,
though it involved 26 different
circuits, one for each letter.
And it was based on the fact
that the battery providing
the current can be placed at
a distance away from the jars
containing the leads
creating the bubbles.
An inventive, although
clumsy system,
which was never adopted.
But very soon,
everything changed
after a famous
demonstration in 1819.
It was found that if we simply
pass a wire near a compass
and connect it to a battery, as
soon as the wire made contact
with the battery,
the needle jumped
without any physical contact.
The only explanation was that
the current-carrying wire
was creating a temporary
magnetic field.
This was followed
by a series of tests
to figure out the
direction of this field.
First we assumed it was pointing
along the wire with the current
or perhaps emanating
outwards from the wire,
as heat would travel.
But eventually, it
was deduced that it
must be traveling around the
wire in perpendicular circles.
So a loop of wire would
create a magnetic field,
which points through
the center of the loop
and around the outside.
This led to the
galvanometer, which
was designed to detect and
measure electrical current.
And it was just
simply a coil of wire
with a compass
suspended in the center.
Now when electric current
was applied to the coil,
a magnetic field would push
through the middle of the coil
and around the outside.
So the needle would
always point perpendicular
to the direction
of the force, which
was balanced on either
side of the needle.
And the stronger the current,
the stronger the deflection
of the needle.
And by 1824, William
Sturgeon demonstrated a way
to increase the strength
of this field even more.
Simply by wrapping
a coil of wire
around a piece of
iron, such as a nail,
the magnetic force
could be amplified,
because iron seemed to be a
better medium for supporting
the formation of
magnetic fields.
We call this permeability.
And by wrapping the
wire many times,
the strength of the
field could be amplified
thousands of times, and this
is known as an electromagnet.
So suddenly, it was possible
to create magnetic fields which
could move needles
with precision
and force using electric
current applied at a distance,
using a long loop of wire
and a strong battery.
At the time, our
understanding of information
was in its infancy.
People were thinking about
information in a message,
and as the number of
letters in a message.
So the goal was intuitive.
Who could come up
with the fastest way
to transmit letters?
And whoever had
the fastest system
would therefore reduce
the cost per message
for the sender
using this system.
And a gold mine was waiting
for whoever got there first.